even outside of quantum computers some
of the theories that we've been talking
about what's your hope what's most
promising to test these theories what
are what are kind of experiments we can
conduct whether in simulation or in the
physical world that would validate or
disprove or expand these theories well I
think for the there's two parts of that
question one is many worlds and the
other one is sort of emergent space-time
for many worlds you know there are
experiments on going to test whether or
not wavefunction spontaneously collapse
and if they do then that rules out many
worlds and that would be falsified what
if there are hidden variables there's a
theorem that seems to indicate that the
predictions will always be the same as
many worlds I'm a little skeptical this
theorem I'm not completely I haven't
internalized that I haven't made it in
part of my intuitive view of the world
yet so there might be loopholes to that
theorem I'm not sure about that a part
of me thinks that there should be
different experimental predictions if
there are hidden variables but I'm not
sure but otherwise it's just quantum
mechanics all the way down and so
there's there's this cottage industry in
science journalism of writing breathless
articles that say you know quantum
mechanics shown to be more astonishing
than ever before thought and really it's
the same quantum mechanics we've been
doing since 1926 whereas with the
emergent space-time stuff we know a lot
less about what the theory is it's in a
very primitive state we don't even
really have a safely written down
respectable honest theory yet so there
could very well be experimental
predictions we just don't know about yet
that is one of the things that we're
trying to figure out before emergence
space-time you need a really big stuff
all right
well or really fast stuff or really
energetic stuff we don't know that's the
thing you know so there could be
violations of the speed of light if you
have emergent space-time not going
faster than the speed of light but the
speed of light could be different for
light of different wavelengths right
that would be a dramatic violation of
physics as we know it but it could be
possible or not I mean it's not an
absolutely prediction as that's that's
the problem the theories are just not
well developed enough yet to say
you